i mean it makes me a little bit sad
because
your work is both uh
from a computer science perspective
fascinating and the inference engine
from uh epistemological philosophical
aspect fascinating
but you know it is also you're running a
company
and there's some stuff that has to
remain private
and it's sad well here's something that
may make you feel better a little bit
better um
we're um we've formed a uh not
not-for-profit company uh called the
knowledge activitization institute next
knax
and
i have this firm belief with a lot of
empirical evidence to support it that
the
the education that people get in high
schools in colleges in graduate schools
and so on
is
almost completely orthogonal to almost
completely irrelevant to
how good they're going to be at coming
up to speed in doing this kind of
ontological engineering and writing
these assertions and rules and so on in
in psych and so very often we'll
interview
candidates who have their phd in
philosophy who've taught logic for years
and so on and they're just they're just
awful but the converse is true so one of
the best ontological engineers we ever
had never graduated high school
and so the purpose of
knowledge examination institute if we
can get some some foundations to help
support it is
identify
people in the general population maybe
high school dropouts
who have latent talent
for this sort of thing
offer them
effectively scholarships to train them
and then help place them in companies
that need more trained ontological
engineers some of which would be working
for us but mostly would be working for
partners or customers or something and
if we could do that that would create an
enormous number of
relatively very high paying jobs for
people who currently have no no way out
of some you know
situation that they're locked into so is
there something you can put into words
that describes
somebody who would be great at
ontological engineering so what
characteristics about a person make them
a great at this task this task
of converting
the messiness of human language and
knowledge into formal logic this is very
much like what alan turing had to do
during world war ii uh in trying to find
people to bring to bletchley park where
he would publish in the london times
cryptic crossword puzzles
along with some some innocuous looking
note which essentially said if you were
able to solve this puzzle in less than
15 minutes please call this phone number
and so on so
um you know or back when i was young
there was uh
the practice of having matchbooks where
on the inside of the matchbook
there would be a can you draw this you
have a career in art
a commercial art if you can copy this uh
drawing that you know and so on so um
yes the the analog of that is there a
little test to get to the core of
whether you're gonna be good or not so
part of it has to do with uh being able
to um make and appreciate um um and
react negatively appropriately to puns
and other jokes so you have to have a
kind of sense of humor and if you're
good at
telling jokes and
good at understanding jokes that's
that's one indicator
yes like dad jokes yes well maybe not
dad jokes but real but funny jokes um
but uh i think i'm applying to work as
psycho yeah but um another another is if
you're able to introspect so very often
um
uh we'll we will give someone a simple
question and we'll say like um
what what why why is this and you know
sometimes they'll just say because it is
okay that's a bad sign but very often
they'll be able to introspect and so on
so one of the questions um i often ask
is i'll point to a sentence with a
pronoun in it and i'll say um you know
the reference of that pronoun is
obviously this noun over here
you know how would you or i or an a.i or
a five-year-old ten-year-old child know
that that pronoun refers to that noun
over here
and
often
the people who are going to be good at
ontological engineering will give me
some causal explanation or will refer to
some things that are true in the world
so if you imagine a sentence like the
horse was led into the barn while its
head was still wet
and so its head refers to the horse's
head
but how do you know that and so some
people will say i just know it some
people will say well the horse was the
subject of the sentence and i'll say
okay well what about the horse was led
into the barn while its roof was still
wet now its roof obviously refers to the
barn um and so then they'll say oh well
that's because it's the closest noun and
so on so basically if they try to give
me answers which are based on syntax and
grammar and so on that's a really bad
sign but if they're able to say things
like well horses have heads and barns
don't and barns have roofs and horses
don't
then that's a positive sign that they're
going to be good at this because they
can introspect on what's true in the
world
that leads you to know certain things
how fascinating is it that getting a phd
makes you less capable to introspect
deeply about this kind of oh i wouldn't
i wouldn't
i'm not saying that it makes you less
capable let's just say it's independent
of oh i don't know how of how good
people are you're not saying that i'm
saying that there's a certain kind it's
it's interesting
that for a lot of people uh phds uh
sorry philosophy aside that sometimes
education narrows your thinking versus
expands it yes it's kind of fascinating
and for certain when you're trying to do
ontological engineering which is
essentially teach our future ai
overlords how to
reason deeply about this world and how
to understand it
that that requires that you think deeply
about the world so i'll tell you a sad
story about math craft which is why is
that not widely used in schools today um
we're not really trying to make
big profit on it or anything like that
when we we've gone to schools their
attitude has been well
if a student spends
20 hours going through this math craft
program from start to end and so on
will it improve their score on this
standardized test more than if they
spent 20 hours just doing mindless
drills of problem after problem after
problem and the answer is well no but
it'll increase their understanding more
and their attitude is well if it doesn't
increase their score on this test
um then that's not you know we're not
going to adopt it
you